what's going on guys this is rob which
by the way we will do a episode 2 miss
marvel review honestly the show's cool
it was fun not a whole lot happened in
episode two so whatever it was cool uh
here's the thing we've never really
talked about the boys so far and here's
a reason why the first you know when it
came to the first two seasons they kind
of deviated away from the comics a
little bit this third season i really
wanted to see
what they were gonna do right i wanted
to give it a few episodes to kind of
figure out you know where they were
going and how they were handling it and
all that kind of stuff i love what
they're doing right like i love the boys
comic book series it's an amazing comic
book series but i love the fact that
they changed things for the show because
if they had just done a complete carbon
copy of the comics in real life it would
have been boring and i would have just
turned it off because i would have known
exactly how things were going to end so
i would have been like whatever i've
seen this i know what happens but i love
their changing things up now the way in
which they're changing things in season
three is starkly different from what
they've done for what they were doing in
the comics so we'll explain some things
in the comments or i'll give you guys
some revelations in the comics in terms
of how it compares to the shows but fyi
while i wouldn't say they're spoilers
because they haven't happened yet
there's the potential that it might
happen so just be aware of that
potential possible spoiler for stuff
that goes on later in the show so let's
talk about homelander here for a second
one i love the idea that homelanders
going crazy when it comes to homelander
in the show i'm sorry in the comics
here's the here's the thing right this
is one of those this is one of those
spoiler things so just fyi huge spoiler
here potentially for the show
homelander going nuts does happen
slowly
but the idea of him coming up with like
the scheme to conquer the world
basically doesn't really happen until
herogasm you could kind of tell in the
comics it was getting to that point that
he was kind of like okay obviously
homelander's coming to the realization
the world needs him more than he needs
the world and it'd be pretty easy for
him to basically just conquer everything
right to just kill everybody at vaught
to take out the president congress the
whole nine yards and conquer it all and
he does right in the comics he does in
the comics he literally he takes out
virtually everybody now you end up with
a fight between him and black noir in
the white house and basically they die
but the thing about it is like this
doesn't necessarily happen this shift
doesn't happen until you get to herogasm
that's when he calls together basically
all the differing superheroes and is
like let's just conquer the world right
why can't we rule this place i mean we
don't need thought american like we can
just take everything we can just do
whatever we want so that happens later
on right that happens after hirogasm not
necessarily as soon as you're seeing it
now and he never really became the kind
of like ceo of vaughn american the way
that you're seeing it done here i guess
the owner or the chairman or the head or
whatever you want to call it it was
never really that way there was always
somebody with pulling the strings
because the reality here is vaughn
american and the boys there's way more
exposure to this company in the show
than there ever was in the comics and
the comics vaught was just kind of this
clandestine organization out there that
ruled everything and for reasons that
just really added to the ambiguity and
the mystery there they were able to
control the superheroes now a lot of
that was because it seemed like the
superheroes were conditioned to believe
that how they were viewed in the public
eye was the most important thing right
they were all about fame money sex drugs
rock and roll like all that kind of
stuff right so they kind of bought into
all those different things but
homelander as he's progressed now it's
basically how he is in the comics after
he orgasm just happening at a different
place now as i understand it hirogasm is
happening right here orgasm is actually
going to take place and it screwed up
the staff when they did it like the the
whole acting crew they were like this
was a ridiculously debaucherous thing
the other thing is in the in the show
they hated this idea that queen maeve
has always hated homelander it wasn't
that way at least not in the comics in
the comics
she really was all about homelander in
the beginning what had happened it was
one of the darkest moments right like
okay i'll tell you and then and then
we'll kind of talk about why you know
why it was sold or at least it was it
was messed up so what happened is
homelander and queen made they had they
had a relationship together right they
were just knocking they were banging
like rabbits
what homelander did is he basically
tricked queen maeve in the sense that he
basically was like he was gonna do some
really kinky stuff right blindfolded her
the two of them were going to go at it
and then eventually she realized that
what he had done is tricked her into
having sex with black noir and then he
was taking pictures of it and then he
sent those pictures out to everybody
right just to humiliate her for no other
reason than the fact that he just wanted
to humiliate her after that she broke up
with him and she's hated him ever since
honestly that was one of the major
contributing factors in the comics to
her becoming an alcoholic and basically
just drowning herself like just drowning
herself in alcohol right now eventually
she ends up defecting and joining billy
butcher stuff like that like what you're
seeing in the show right now but that
leads into the to the general discussion
about the heroes in the boys the heroes
kind of have redeeming qualities right
like they're like okay you know like not
all of them believe that what they're
doing is the right thing or they were so
caught up in the life they were never
considering the consequences of their
actions and now they are and things are
turning around no no in the comics there
were no redeeming qualities about the
superheroes not one i mean you had some
who were kind of good guys but not
really like starlight is like one of the
only real exceptions queen maeve you
could argue makes a makes a good
exception in the sense that she joined
billy butcher later on but by and large
there's no redeeming qualities about the
superheroes right this is not some
anakin in return of the jedi when he's
like you know tell your sister you were
right like no no no there's none of that
stuff right like they're just dicks in
the comics they're just terrible
terrible people so the the best way to
highlight this is a train right because
in the tv show you guys know how it all
goes right a train is kind of seeing the
error of his ways and trying to make
amends for his past misdeeds and his
arrogance and not caring about his
community and all that kind of stuff
uh-uh in the comics no no no a train
never apologized he never felt bad right
and even the boys kind of laughed off
what it was that he did to starlight and
they kind of swept it under the rug
eventually in the comics there's a point
where you end up finding out the only
reason why the boys brought starlight on
is so they could sleep with her that was
the only reason right and then uh
following that there comes a point where
huey kills a train because a train had
killed robin at one you know at the the
beginning of the story which is why huey
ended up joining the boys in the first
place but you know there's no character
evolution like what you're seeing in the
show a train doesn't feel bad about what
he did in the comics not really not ever
right it's just he's just a terrible
person but having said that i loved the
way this progressed and i love the way
the shows progressed so far especially
this season really more than any of the
others the one thing that i thought was
really interesting i wouldn't say bad
but i would say interesting is the
legend and the reason why is because the
the significance of the legend in the
comics is that's the guy that has all
the information that's the guy who knows
how vaude american became bought
american right a little bit of a spoiler
here and you know maybe we'll make a
different video on that well we'll kind
of talk about the the history of what
and whatnot but the guy knows the whole
history right he's got it all right he's
the guy that you talk to the guy that
that brokers all that stuff to everybody
so it's one of those things where the
the kind of history there is that it's
not really mother's milk that's tied
closely to the legend it's actually
billy butcher now again it's not a great
big huge issue that they changed it you
know i'm not so hell-bent that like they
can't change anything from like it was
in the comics right i mean i'm not i'm
not that far gone but it is interesting
that they chose to do that having said
that the most interesting thing about
the entirety of this season this is the
most this is the most mind-blowing thing
to me
is what they're doing with soldier boy
right like i love soldier boy in season
three i love i wish soldier boy in
season three as he exists now that
that's the way he'd been in the comics
in the comics soldier boy he was just
useless as tits on a boar hawk that guy
served no purpose whatsoever right now
here's the funny thing obviously you can
tell just by looking at the character
he's a play on captain america the
difference is that in the show
it's more of a question of like what if
captain america had basically gone
through everything bucky barnes had gone
through and then just was always kind of
a jerk and basically was more kind of
evil now i guess i mean we have yet to
see whether or not he's actually evil he
really just seems like a guy with a
vendetta to be honest and even when he
was younger it didn't necessarily seem
like he was an evil guy so much as just
young and brash and cocky caught away
with him you know caught up in himself
and that was basically it right you know
a person with powers that had no no
restraint and no consequences for the
things they did uh so i wouldn't really
classify him as a bad guy but in the
comics no no no he was it was uh he was
a parody of captain america if anything
he was naive he would have phrases like
golly gee and he really believed that
what he was doing like like him
operating as a superhero that he was
actually that person it's like he just
hadn't caught on to the fact that like
it's all basically marketing that it's
all just kind of a great big show put on
by vaude american he wasn't like a the
kind of character you think of when you
think of uh when you see soldier boy now
right when you think of captain america
you know you think of you think of him
as a captain america who was naive who
was wide-eyed who had no idea what was
really going on was more of like a child
pretending to be a superhero than an
adult who was actually paying attention
to what was what was taking place you
know what i mean you know this just that
kind of thing now one of the significant
roles that soldier boy had which is one
of the big differences between the show
and the comics right now is that soldier
boy was ultimately interrogated by billy
butcher and they got a ton of
information out of him because that's
one of the things to know billy butcher
it was it was one of those things where
sometimes he would work with superheroes
but he would rather not he would rather
just destroy them every chance he gets
which for the most part he kind of does
the only ones that he really worked with
on a regular basis were starlight and
only because of huey and queen maeve
only because of the information she
could provide and like that was
basically it but beyond that there
really wasn't a whole else going on
there but again you know i'm loving the
boys season three i'm loving the way
that it's unfolding the real question
here
is are they gonna do the black noir
reveal that's the question that i have
because i saw a lot of people out there
who were just kind of like i mean they
showed us who black noir was way back in
like the the flashback from mallory and
all that kind of stuff but here's the
thing right with soldier boy for example
that was a legacy title there were
soldier boys who existed before the main
soldier boy that we saw in the boys
comics like captain america is a legacy
title different things like that and so
when it comes to uh black noir it may
very well be and i agree with a lot of
the theories on this it may very well be
that black noir that we saw in the
flashback was like a prototype or it was
the original black noir but following
that and the destruction of that guy
they basically went back and reworked
the concept and then we have the black
noir that we have right now which would
make a lot more sense because
the the only thing i will tell you
without offering a massive spoiler the
only thing that i will tell you is
yes black noir is a member of the seven
but he's more of a fail-safe
it's more he's more of like a like smash
glass in case of emergency kind of guy
like that's the that's the character
that he is not going to tell you
anything more than that although i
imagine a lot of you guys have probably
looked it up and already seen the story
behind black noir but those are guys who
have and who aren't who don't want to
spoil it for yourself that's that's
that's the case there but regardless i'm
hyped i love what's going on i love the
character dynamics and all that kind of
stuff so again you know we'll continue
on with the reviews and different things
like that you know again i'm it's tough
staying organized with all this because
there's so much stuff coming out at one
time but yeah at any event guys we're
going to bring this to an end thank you
guys for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace